kids enough Miss
Hager uh who's
this I'm tempted to ask the same she's
joking how can I help
you Mia a student a not a broken Spirit
yeah that's something it's lovely to see
you in the wild I have a
story I I just need to talk to you just
for a second could we just for a
second
Ella here is with the
guardian so you have got two expert
ears what about yours oh I was talking
about
mine go ahead now did you come here to
tell me
tomorrow can can I sit no Ty sh she's
pitching okay okay um it's it's like a
profile piece the other night I was out
on on this dat and the guy starts don't
make the story about you it's not it's
not it's this kid he's like barely 15 he
just appears out of nowhere stands up
for me gets knocked down seems like this
Dickens urch him but I go back to his
place and it's huge turns out he's
Charlotte Novak's kid you know the
writer yeah that story was milked to
death for about a week I seem to
remember your hands all over those
utters that isn't the story well the
story is a strange woman alone in a huge
house with a kid who's a minor no it's I
lost my mom too
how excuse me well I assume you're
telling me that cuz you have some sort
of personal Insight here so I'm
clarifying um
well it's complicated ah any what I can
tell you is that everybody talks about
these tragedies like they statistics but
never about the ones who aren't in The
Numbers Never about what can grow from
the darkness like he's this amazing
artist so it would be like a phoenix in
the ashes profiles no one cares about
the
kid a lonely kid drawing in a big house
is not a story no but I mean you do have
something pretty sure the Novac refused
all interviews in the wake of
Charlotte's death that's why there was
so much
speculation now if you've got an in with
one of them I think there could be more
to uncover there if you
can I also think I need the restroom
M good luck thank
you you could have put all of that in an
email or a bottle in the ocean she liked
it she was being
polite you
know you're going to have to work twice
as hard you're going to be clamoring
over so many people who are way more
talented than you are nervous
you're going to need to be exceptional I
can get something
compelling well get
it